a
[Música]
ah
el independentismo catalán está muy
debilitado y unas nuevas elecciones
anticipadas en la comunidad autónoma
parecen inevitables en pocos días se
despega a la sentencia del tribunal
supremo español que seguramente
inhabilitada al presidente catalán el
quinto capo que como vemos el caso de la
pancarta a favor de los presos catalanes
que estaba en la fachada del palacio de
la generalitat en plena campaña
electoral pese a su prohibición en caso
de que se confirmase esta inhabilitación
pues hoy pongo una parte la policía
catalana teme unos nuevos disturbios en
las calles como los que sacudió en
barcelona el año pasado y por otra se
convocarían unos nuevos comicios en los
próximos meses pero no está nada claro
el que el independentismo de la derecha
y la izquierda que gobiernan en
coalición actualmente el puesto pueda
volver a ganar y sobre todo gobernar
juntos
ya que hace meses que la división entre
ambos partidos es evidente
[Música]
a 6 años del referéndum por la
independencia de escocia la opinión
pública ha cambiado en favor de
independizarse del resto del reino
unido- los vientos soplan en favor de
una escocia independiente según las
últimas encuestas de opinión 53 %
contaría en favor de independizarse del
reino unido según los expertos y el
creciente apoyo para una escocia
independiente se debe a la salida del
reino unido- de la unión europea el prep
sigue a la que los escoceses siempre se
han opuesto además la primera ministra
de escocia la independentista a nicole
exterior asegura que si hay bases y
fundamentos para un segundo referéndum
sin embargo el gobierno central de
westminster advierte que no autorizará
una segunda consulta y que el tema quedó
resuelto de una vez y para siempre en el
referéndum de 2014
[Música]
que ve que es una provincia famosa por
ser una isla francesa y católica en un
país de mayoría inglesa y protestante
también por los dos referendos en los
80s y 90s que decidieron por márgenes
estrechos que quebec se quedaría en
canadá actualmente cree que está
habiendo resurgido nacionalismo bajo el
liderazgo de france colgó un ex 'para'
artista y ahora líder de la coalición a
venir quebec o cac y recientemente el
ente de vigilancia que hace cumplir las
normas sobre el uso del francés en la
provincia recibió una inyección de 5
millones de dólares aún así otro
referendo independentista parece no ser
una opción para el eco para el apoyo
público ha fluctuado aunque las más
recientes encuestas registran que
alrededor de una tercera parte de la
población favorece la independencia como
explicó la profesora de sociología clerc
dijo a france 24 cada vez más personas
en la provincia se identifican con una
identidad quebequense aunque querer la
independencia por esta razón es cada vez
menos común
[Música]